Making the Web faster is important not just to Google...
...but we believe it's important to everybody.
The Web has become the dominant competing platform of our time.
It's the platform by which people communicate socially.
It's the way we exchange ideas.
It's the platform that runs the applications we care most about.
And by making the Web as fast as it can be, we think the whole world benefits.
I think the most immediate impact will be...
...the number of people using the Web will just increase dramatically.
You're gonna see more high-speed and faster performing phones...
...and mobile devices in people's hands.
New markets can form.
People will be making purchasing decisions on-the-spot,...
...instead of, you know, going back home and sitting down at their computer.
So, there are a lot of, I think, future benefits to be had.
And I think the world can really benefit from having information access faster.
We should also hold out as a goal, as an aspiration for what we could achieve...
...by making the Internet a faster place...
...is raising the quality of life around the world.